maybe nights where I've cried and I've
never prayed more in my life that's pink
opening up about the reality of her and
her son Jameson's or deal with kovat 19
[Music]
and it's not guaranteed there's no one
that is safe from this the 40 year old
revealed just how scary things got
during an Instagram live interview with
author Jen pastel off on Sunday
she's been really really sick it's been
really really scary and it's been really
up and down and I've been on nebulizers
for the first time in 30 years and
that's been really scary for me I'm
hoping that we're out of the woods but
this thing is a roller coaster like just
when you think you're better something
else happens pink says despite her and
her three-year-old son contracting the
virus her husband Carey Hart and their
eight-year-old daughter Willow have
managed to stay healthy and while the
songstress says she's mostly feeling
better Jamison still isn't 100%
we got tested Jameson's been really
really sick I've kept a journal of his
symptoms have you three weeks and mine
as well and he's still three weeks later
has a hundred temperature last Friday
pink revealed on Instagram that both she
and Jamison had tested positive for
köppen 19 I totally understand my people
are pissed off about that I totally
understand I had two tests before the
labs could even get them right of course
yeah and I was lucky enough to get to
test because my because we were about to
sick and because I paint money for them
and I think it's a failure a failure a
complete failure of the government
that we can't all just get tested right
now in that same post the singer also
revealed that she's donating 1 million
dollars to support medical workers on
the front lines and it turns out her
daughter inherited that giving gene too
tonight I had told her that I had made a
donation to the hospital that her
grandma her mom worked out for 18 years
and she went out got her money that she
made on tour and got it together and I
was like what are you doing and she was
like I want to give everything I want to
give my money to the hospital too and so
she gave me all her tour money pig joins
Tom Hanks Rita Wilson Sara Bareilles and
other celebs who have announced that
they've contracted Koba 19 during the
ongoing global pandemic
[Music]